Welcome guys and girls. Today we are
going to go over some of the popular
cloud interview questions including the
new genai ones. More importantly, I'm
going to go over some of the average
answer that I hear from candidates all
the time as well as some of the real
world good answers. If you give answers
like that, you will set yourself apart
from others and will increase your
chance of getting the job significantly.
The questions we are going to cover
today are what are the differences
between SQL and NoSQL? What is RAG in
Genai? What are some Genai use cases?
What is the difference between CI/CD and
GitHubs? What is RTO and RPO? Tell me a
microservices design in AWS. How do you
pick one service versus another as a
solutions architect? What is your
favorite AWS service? How will you
improve it further? What is AWS service
X? For those of you who are new to the
channel, my name is Raj. I'm currently a
principal specialist solutions architect
working at AWS. Before joining AWS, I
was a distinguished cloud architect at
Verizon. Before that, I was a mainframer
at JP Morgan Chase. So, I worked in
mainframe for over 10 years and able to
switch my career. I have delivered
critical real world projects which
became official AWS references. But more
importantly, I have mentored students
who got into top companies. They came
from legacy technology as well. But now
I have helped them got into AWS, Google,
JP Morgan Chase, Reddit, City Bank and
more. And they followed the same
framework that I'm going to teach you
today. Okay, let's get started. Super
popular question, difference between SQL
and NoSQL. And most of you think you
answered it correctly. The answer I hear
a lot is SQL holds structured data and
NoSQL handles semistructured and
unstructured data. SQL needs a schema.
NoSQL is schemaless. Is this answer
correct? Yes. But this is bare minimum.
Why is it average or why is it bad? SQL
and NoSQL has been out for a long time.
So at this point interviewer expects
more. What the interviewer is looking
for is how this impacts different design
factors and how you will choose one
versus the other. Keep in mind as a
solutions architect you will be
responsible for talking to the
application team and coming up with
appropriate databases. So you need to go
beyond just these two factors. A good
answer. Of course, you have to say those
points. They will start there. But then
you have to also talk about SQL
databases need to scale vertically for
the writer instances. And NoSQL
databases scale
horizontally. SQL databases support
complex queries and joins. NoSQL
databases do not support complex queries
and joins. SQL generally follows acid
properties and NoSQL follows cap
theorem. No SQL database is inherently
highly available but in SQL you are
responsible for that part. Even better
add any personal experience if you have.
For example, at company X during a
release of a very popular product we
chose Dynamob to hold the information
and the price of that product which
handled 10 times the regular traffic
without latency or scale issues. See how
this is different than the average
answers. This answer shows the
theoretical difference of course but
then you also know the design
properties, the scalability, high
availability and how SQL and NoSQL
impacts each of those along with your
practical experience. Now Genai is super
popular and even in general solutions
architect interviews you are expected to
know the fundamentals of Genai. So rag
is one of those concepts. So one
question is what is rag in genai? So you
may say rag stands for retrieval
augmented generation. It is a technique
where a language model retrieves
relevant information from external
sources before generating a response.
This helps the model provide more
accurate answers especially when it has
not been trained on the latest data. Is
this correct answer? Yes, but it's an
average answer. Right? Because everyone
will say this. Why is it average? The
basics are correct, but it does not show
the knowledge of solutions architect. It
doesn't go a little bit deeper. It
doesn't talk about the actual use cases.
An actual good answer will explain what
does rag mean. And I'm just showing a
design to explain it. Of course, in a
verbal interview, you won't be able to
draw a design, but it's a good one to
keep in your back pocket in case this
comes in your system design round as
well. So you could say rag stands for
retrieval augmented generation. So the
flow is like this. You the user can ask
a question to the large language model.
But instead of sending the question
directly to the large language model, we
are going to augment that with
additional context. What do let's say
you are an automotive company and the
user is asking about the latest model
for 2026 which is not in large language
model yet. So the organization will get
the information about the latest model
and then using another embedding model
convert them to vectors or embeddings
and save them into a knowledge base such
as Amazon open search or Amazon Kendra.
When a customer asks a question, a code
or a notebook will go to this vector
database where these embeddings are
stored and search for any relevant
context. If it is found, it will grab
all those additional information and
then it will augment the question with
additional context and then send it to
another large language model. All these
large language models and knowledge
bases can be stored in example Amazon
service such as Amazon bedrock. After
getting this question with the context,
large language model will generate an
appropriate answer and send it to the
user. Because of this whole operation,
retrieving relevant information,
augmenting that information in the
context as well as generating the final
answer is where the name rag comes in
with. Some of the popular use cases of
rag are chatbot or question answer based
systems where up-to-ate information is
important. Notice how I'm demonstrating
my thought process as a solutions
architect and not just giving a
theoretical question answer. Next one.
What are some jai use cases? Average
answer chatbots, chat GPT, genai coding.
Why are the average? These are outdated.
If I asked you this question like a one
year back and you gave me these answers,
they would have been a great answer. But
at this point, everyone knows about
chatbot, chat GPT, Genaii coding
assistants like Amazon Q developer or
copilot etc. This has no association
with enterprise use cases and it's
missing latest
enhancements. Okay. So how would a good
answer look like? A good answer would
look like GNAI use cases can be divided
into three broad categories. Enhancing
customer experience, improving
productivity and some of the latest
cuttingedge use cases. How do I enhance
customer experience with Genai? chat
bots and virtual assistants even agentic
assistance where the customers chats
with the agent and the agent using
latest technology like rag knowledge
group gather relevant information even
take actions there have been lot of
enhancements in improving the
productivity for example genai can
generate content if your enterprise has
lot of reports and you want to summarize
them or generate new report from them ji
could be useful about that. Another use
case in this area that's emerging is you
ask Genai to create a metrics in natural
language and genai will create the
analysis including the metrics and
dashboard for you. One such example is
Amazon Q with quicksite and also one of
the very popular geni use case is doing
the coding to assist developer
increasing productivity by 10x or more.
And finally, there are some cutting edge
use cases that I have been playing with
and have been super fun. So for example,
S activities with MCP or model context
protocol. For example, I work
extensively with Kubernetes cluster. I
actually use the Kubernetes MCP server
to troubleshoot and fix some of the
errors in Kubernetes. By the way, I have
a separate video along with demo. I'm
going to give the link up top. So feel
free to go check it out. There are many
different MCP servers available not just
for Kubernetes but for coding cost
analysis best practices etc. They can
all be used for debugging purposes and I
also analyzed my AWS cost using AWS cost
analysis server and optimized my cost.
See how this is different. It shows that
you understand the different use cases
of Genai as well as the different
distinct areas and it connects it to the
enterprise use cases that your
interviewer cares about. If you want to
go one level deeper and get personally
trained by me like hundreds of my
students and crack top tech jobs such as
AWS, Microsoft, Google, Ready, JP Morgan
City. Check out sab bootcamp.com. I run
few cohorts with selected students
throughout the year. If interested, wait
list there and when the next cohort
opens up, you will get notified. Next
question. What is the difference between
traditional CI/CD and GitHubs? But I'm
going to go over some of the bad answer
traits. No clear understanding of CI and
CD. Most of the candidates just club
them together. But remember CI and CD
are different phases and within each CI
and CD there are multiple steps. Just
Google it or look up for my other videos
on CI/CD. You have to remember each
phase of CI and CD and what belongs to
what. And this is another mistake that
candidates do. CICD is not fully
replaced by GitHubs. Only the CD part is
replaced by GOPS. But a lot of times
candidates say yes I have replaced the
CI/CD with GitHubs which is a wrong
answer. Now a good answer will use an
actual use case right because anytime
you use a use case number one it's
easier to explain number two it changes
you from a theoretical memorized answer
candidate to someone who has actually
worked in this technology. Now of course
GitHubs is related to Kubernetes
container use cases. So I'll go real
quick. So in traditional CI/CD with
containers, the flow will look like
this. You will check in the code, docker
file and some of the manifests into a g
repository and that will trigger some CI
tools such as genkins or code builder
etc. that will take all this code and
docker file and create the container
image. then the CD tool will get
triggered and this CD tool will go and
update the Kubernetes manifest such as
deployment manifest with the new
container image tag. So when this
container is created, it will have an
updated tag like a release version or
something and then this CD tool will go
and update this manifest and point it to
this new container image using this new
tag. As soon as this manifest file is
changed, the CD tool such as Genkins
will deploy this manifest file to a
Kubernetes cluster possibly running in
Amazon EKS and then as soon as this new
EML is deployed that will bring the
container image to your Kubernetes
cluster. Now this is the important part
even with GitHubs the CI part stays the
same. So this is the CI part, right? So
when the user checks in the code and etc
to the container image creation the part
that changes is the CD part. So even
here a CD tool will go and update the
manifest with the container image tag.
However in the traditional CI/CD the CD
tool is pushing the file into this
Amazon EKS and the pushpull is from the
perspective of the Kubernetes cluster.
the genkins or some other tool is
pushing the file with GitHubs. A GitHubs
tool is installed in the cluster and it
constantly reconciles between the
version that's running in the cluster
versus the one that's in the git. That's
why the name Githops is there, right? G
becomes the single source of truth. As
soon as the file in the g is changed,
this Argo CD, which is the most popular
GitHub tool right now, grabs this YAML
file and brings it to the Kubernetes
cluster. And as soon as this file is
brought in, so in the HCD, you'll have a
desired state which is defined in this
manifest and the current state or
running state which is actually running.
As soon as these two are different, a
controller will deploy this container
image because remember this manifest
file has the updated tag. So then the
container image will come in and get
deployed into this Amazon EKS. So also
study some of the advantages of GitHubs.
I have a separate video. I will give the
link up top. I don't know how many links
YouTube will let me give in the up top
but I'll try to give it. Next one. What
is RTO and RPO? Average answer is RTO
stands for recovery time objective and
RPO stands for recovery point object
objective. RTO signifies how much time
an application can be down in case of a
disaster and RPO measures how much data
can you lose in case of disaster. Why
this is an average answer? This is very
vague and highlevel answer. Now this is
where most people make a mistake. Most
people mess with unit of measurement.
They give a wrong answer here. They say
RTO is measured in time because it's
recovery time objective, right? And RPO
stands for recovery point and then it
measures how much data and they say RPO
is measured in unit of data like
megabyte, gigabyte, pabyte etc. which is
wrong. In some cases, candidates try to
avoid it and don't go to it. But as an
interviewer we know this comes up in our
actual conversations with customer. So
you cannot wait for me to ask you this.
You have to show interviewer that you
know this. Okay. And always think the
question behind the question. You are a
solutions architect. Right? Why is RTO
and RPO important? That's what is
covered in the good answer. Good answer
you could say. RTO stands for recovery
time objective and RPO stands for
recovery point objective. RTO signifies
the maximum acceptable time it should
take to restore the application after a
disaster or disruption and RPO measured
maximum acceptable amount of data loss
after the failure. Both RTO and RPO are
measured in time. Even RPO is measured
in time. What does that mean? How is it
measured in time? So let's say you took
a backup at 100 p.m. and you take backup
every 1 hour. So let's say you took a
backup at 1 p.m. and before the next
backup happens after 1 hour the system
goes down. So at this point you can only
restore up to the last backup, right?
Which is at 1:00. So you lose up to 1
hours of data max. Whereas let's say uh
you take backup every uh 10 minutes. So
1:00 110 120 30 40 50. Okay. So even if
the application goes down at
15959 maximum amount of data you could
lose is 10 minutes worth right because
you took a backup at 150. So that's how
RPO is also measured in time. So if you
want to reduce RPO take frequent
backups. And if you want to eliminate
RPO what does that mean? That means you
just have to do real time replication of
your data. Why is RTO and RPO important?
Based on RTO and RPO, we can select one
of the four AWS disaster recovery
strategies. See question behind the
question. So there is a good graph. You
can Google it. RTORP disaster recovery.
This will come up. It will say there are
the four disaster recovery strategies.
Backup and restore, pilot light, warm
standby, multi-sight active active.
Backup and restore has the highest RTOR
RPO but lowest cost. Multicight active
active has the lowest RPO almost real
time but the highest cost. You should
study up one of the DR strategies in a
little bit more depth because another
popular interview follow-up question is
can you explain to me one of the
disaster recovery strategies that you
are familiar with? My favorite is
multicight active active because it
shows your knowledge in multiple areas.
Knowledge in networking, compute,
database, etc. But as long as you study
one in depth, you should be okay. Okay.
Next one. Hey Mr. candidate, can you
design a microser in AWS or can you tell
me a micros service design? Average
answer is I will use application load
balancer with EC2 or application load
balancer with EKS or API gateway with
lambda. Why is this average? You have to
explain how the design actually works.
Remember you are in a solutions
architect interview. Okay, you have to
showcase that you know how the design
works. Not just LB with EC2 with
autoscaling group etc. Right? The
question is how will you design a micros
service? Okay. Or tell me about a micros
service design. So you have to highlight
micros service characteristics in the
design. Okay. So a good answer will look
like this. Yes. Let me explain a micros
service design with a very popular
service application load balancer. So
application load balancer can be
associated with Amazon route 53. And
with Amazon route 53 you could have a
proper DNS name for example
www.store.com. Any traffic going to this
domain will be forwarded it to this
application load balancer. Now based on
the URL path, this application load
balancer can do pathbased routing and
send the traffic to different target
groups. For example, with
store.com/browse, it can send the
traffic to a target group which is an
Amazon EC2 in a autoscaling group and
this becomes one micros service and for
these EC2s I could have let's say Amazon
Dynamob which is AWS's flagship NoSQL
database as the storage. for
store.com/purchase I could send the
traffic to another autoscaling group
with EC2s but this is handling real-time
transaction which requires complex
queries and joins so for this I'm going
to use Amazon Aurora and similarly I
could have different target groups for
different paths now this design
highlights some of the microservices
strengths and characteristics for
example each of the microservices is
independent of each other and can be
handled by separating teams. Often even
the tech stack is different. For
example,
store.com/browse can be handled by EC2s
in autoscaling group whereas
store.com/purchase could be handled by
containers running in Kubernetes.
Store.com return could be handled by
lambda. Not only these microservices can
be independently scaled, tested and
deployed because they are all
independent of each other, the compute
as well as the storage. This also
demonstrate a powerful feature of
microser which is polyglot because
different teams are handling these
different
microservices. They could be written in
different programming languages. For
example,
store.com/browse backend could be
written in Python. The container ones
could be written in NodeJS and the
lambda could written in Go. This is how
I will design a microser in AWS which
demonstrates the microser
characteristics as well as superpowers
of some of these AWS services. Now a
popular followup to this question is how
will you pick one service versus another
like in the previous example you
mentioned EC2 you mentioned containers
you mentioned lambda right that's a
really popular follow-up for cloud
interviews especially for solutions
architect so you can ask interviewer
about the system requirements right what
are the design requirements of the
system to show a little bit more depth
and you just have to study for this one
right there are many different questions
why should you use load balancer why not
API gateway or vice versa, SQL versus
NoSQL, etc. So, this is my favorite
subject because as a solutions
architect, this comes up a lot in my
customer conversations and I have bunch
of videos on this. So, check them out. I
will give the playlist link in the
description. Okay, next one. What is
your favorite service? So, that's a
popular one and a lot of you know the
answer to this. The one that you get
stumbled on is how can you improve it or
have you faced any challenges with it.
This is what shows the interviewer that
you actually know this service or you
have actually used it. Pick something
you know do not try to show off. Okay.
Lot of you think the stuff that you do
not know if you mention it then that
makes you better or that impresses the
interviewer. What impresses the
interviewer is if you can demonstrate
depth in these questions. For example, I
asked a candidate, what is your favorite
service? The candidates goes elastic
Kubernetes service, right? I thought,
okay, great. Can you tell me why is it
your favorite? Or can you tell me how
can you scale Kubernetes workload? And
the candidate could not answer. I can
only judge you based on the questions
you answer. So do not think that you
always have to give the name of the most
cutting edge service that you do not
know as an answer. That is not the
intention of this question. Okay, with
that let's go through some popular
services. Okay. When we ask you how can
you improve it or have you faced any
challenge, mention one challenge that
you have fixed and another that requires
intense workaround or no solutions
exist. Right? So it covers both. So one
shows you have faced challenges so you
have worked with it and you know how to
fix it. The other one you wish it's
improved. For example, EC2. So you could
say AMI rehydration is a challenge.
Every time there's a new security
vulnerability, you have to get the
patch, you have to rehydrate it. So then
you can talk about how have you
automated that process. You could use
EC2 image builder, CSC pipeline. Another
challenge is selecting proper instance
types. There's over 800 EC2 instances
available. How would you know what EC2
instance you should select for your
workload? So in that case you could say
we faced this challenge and then we
found out there's a relatively newer
service called compute optimizer which
can analyze your last few weeks of
utilization and then based on that runs
machine learning and then recommends you
the proper instance type and one of the
things you could say that could be done
more you can relate to the shared
responsibility model and you could say
look EC2 has lot of superpower however
at the end of the day we as the customer
are responsible for the AMIs and
readression and all that stuff. Wish
there was an easy button for all of it
where you did not have to orchestrate
some of it. Now let's go to another
popular one. Lambda. You could say
selecting memory is difficult because
Lambda selects up to 10 GB of memory.
You did not know how much memory your
application should require. How did you
overcome this challenge? You used Lambda
insights. Lambda in insights shows
utilization of the memory versus
allocated memory. Based on that you
optimized it. One what is the one thing
you wish lambda had? Maybe running
beyond 15 minutes. You love lambda and
you want to run everything in lambda.
However, currently you cannot process
your long running batching lambda
without extreme overhead or
checkpointing and all that stuff. So you
wish you could run lambda beyond 15
minutes. How about one of the database
RDS? You could say one challenge you
faced was the cost was very high. And
then how did you fix it? You used
reserved instances. So not many people
know this. People always think reserved
instances are just for your regular
EC2s. However, reserved instances are
applicable for regular RDS as well. So
what is reserved instances? Reserved
instances is in return of you committing
to use this instance for one or three
years you enjoy up to 72% discount which
is pretty significant scaling writer
instances is hard right so you have to
do vertical scaling you have to fall
over and before that you have to
implement sharding this that whereas in
NoSQL it takes care of this scaling
automatically so you wish there is
easier way to do that finally a popular
interview question is what is service X
so X could
Lambda, S3,
etc. Lot of you when is asked what is
lambda? You just try to explain it but
then the problem is because you don't
have the official definition. You go
back and forth like it's not succinct.
So this is what I do. I always remember
the official definition then you can add
your own words and explain it. For
example, I'll just give you one example
like lambda. If the interviewer asks
what is AWS Lambda? AWS Lambda is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run code without provisioning or
managing any servers, right? Then you
can explore. Lambda has some of the
other superpowers such as it's pay as
you go, it scales automatically, let me
know if you have any follow-up questions
on any of these questions that I went
over or let me know if any there are any
other questions that you want me to go
over. If you found this video helpful,
please click that like button, smash it
if that's something you are into, and
subscribe. That's it for this one. I'll
see you guys and girls in the next one.
Bye.